はぁ
不穏なBGM
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
はい、えー
ちょっと、報告というか　お知らせというか
まぁ、何人かちょっと気になってくれている方もいると思うんですけども
えー実は昨日ですね。
えー...
夜の、
夜の12時半か！
深夜の12時半に
えー　警察の方に呼ばれて
朝5時半ぐらいまで...
警察署にいました★
あ、俺が捕まったわけじゃねぇぞ
あの、僕が捕まったとかそういう訳じゃないんですけども
ま、ちょっと...
昨日色々ありまして
と、まぁこういうこともあったよってゆうかなんか
まぁ、このあったことをなかったことにするのも嫌だったんで
ま、ちょっと　こういうことがあったよっていうのをちょっと
皆さんにお知らせしようと思います
ま、あの
簡単に説明しますと
えー実は...
ストーカーの被害に遭いました
なぁてつや
て：ﾊｲ！
は：じゃあね
て：ハイ～
は：UUUMおめでとう！
て：あ、ありがｔ(切断
ﾎﾟﾛﾛﾝ
はい、という訳でですね
あの、実は僕も家に監視カメラをしかけておりまして
見に行く！？(ﾄﾞｱｯﾌﾟ
も、ちょっと防犯ちゃんとしなきゃってもう
家がバレちゃってるから
もう防犯はガチでやってるから
家の周りに実は監視カメラを何台か仕掛けています
はい、こんな感じですね
もうこういう感じでもうなんかカメラ動かしたりできるからね！
で、コピーもできるし常に録画はされています
で、時間も出ると！
なので、あの実はですね僕ん家の周りに来た人とかいるともう
全員顔録画してありますから！
あんまりちょっと俺ん家に来るのはお勧めしないと思いますよ僕は
住所がわかってもね？
って感じで昨日ちょっとこう動画編集してたんですけど
なんかちょっと7時
夜の7時前くらいにﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟｰﾝってなって
で、監視カメラ見たら知らない人が立ってました
ｳﾜｯ(引き
と思って
まぁ、ちょっと無視したんですけどピンポンがずっと...
連打されて
挙句の果てにはドアｶﾞﾁｬ×4されて
なんか家の周りグルグル回られたらまた戻ってくる
で、なんか最終的には
玄関の前に座り込まれたりして
結構怖かったです
はい
ｗｗｗ
いや笑うとこじゃねぇ
いや笑うとこじゃなくてホントに怖かったです
一時間程ずっと家の前にいられて
うわこれやべぇなって思って
なんかインターホンで帰ってください的なこと言ったんですけど
帰らないということを言われたので
もしもし、policeman
警察に通報させていただきました
そっからなんすよ‼
そっからが長かったー！
もう警察来るまでずっと待ってぇ！
警察来たら来たで事情聴取が始まってぇ！
もうなんかすげぇ長い時間事情聴取とか
犯人も動かないし
今回はなにもされなかったんですけど
で、一応その人なんか警察署に連れてかれて
すごい怒られてもう二度とすんじゃねぇぞ
オラァ！(殴
あっ...
二度としないでね
みたいな感じで言われたんですけど
ま、そういうのも効かなかった場合
もっとなんかエスカレートして
もう...なんか家の物とか壊されたりしたら
それこそもう事件になるんで
というのを防ぐために
えっと...なんか特別な処置みたいなことを警察の方にしてもらって
禁止命令という...
なんか...
法的拘束をしていただいておりました
禁止命令っていうのがその
今回家の前にいた人が
今後もう一応...
著名は出してなんか所長さんにも通ったらしいので
もし今後その人が
えー、僕に近づいたり何かしたり
もう、なｎ何でも、何かした瞬間
一発逮捕らしいです
即逮捕
即110番でもうなんかパトカーとか来て
そのまま捕まえられるらしいんで！
取り敢えずはまぁ安心...はできないんですけど
まぁ、なんとかなったかなってところではあるんですけども
やっぱ住所バレてるんで家の前に待たれたりすると
出れじゃないですか家から
どうしようもなくて一応なんか
家の中に何人か友達とかはいたんですけど
なかなか怖かったッスね～
でそのなんか禁止命令の書類を書くのに警察署に連れてかれて
書類書いたり事情聴取されたり
監視カメラの映像を一緒に見たり
色んな手続きをしていた一日でございました
はい
という訳で
えー、マジで迷惑でした
なんか初めてちゃんとこういう
ストー→カー↑↑みたいなことをされて
すごい怖かったんで...
なんかよくわかんないんですけど
なんかYouTuberでこういうことがたまにあるみたいなので
マジ普通に容赦なく通報とかしますので
こういう行為はやめてください(ﾍﾟｺﾘ
もし今度その人が何かしてきたら
すぐ速攻逮捕なんで
いやもうなんか怖いんすよね外出るのがちょっと
怖いんすよ！
そんな怖くないけど(怖くないんかい
皆さん、危ない人には気をつけましょうね！(ﾍﾟｺﾘ
じゃあな！
て：バイバ～イ
!?!?!?!?
はーじめしゃちょーおー
今後はー気をつけーてー
危ないーひーとに
襲われないようにー
頑張れ！